[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv
60,18 le journal de la rédaction pour un
condensé d'actualité yvelinoise voici
les titres de ce lundi 10 février un
travail exceptionnel mené par une classe
de 3e du chesnay rocancourt ces
collégiens et leurs professeurs
d'histoire géographie ont développé un
audioguide sur la shoah il revient sur
l'histoire des familles juives de
versailles dans la cité royale justement
ce projet ouvrir un campus des métiers à
la fin de formation aux métiers de l'art
et du patrimoine le dossier est porté
par l'académie de versailles sa rectrice
à charline avenel sera notre invité et
puis le sport malgré la tempête sierra
les rencontres de football se sont bien
déroulées ce dimanche dans les yvelines
retour également sur le tournoi 10
portes qui s'est tenue samedi dans le
département est la tempête sierra pour
débuter qui est passé par les yvelines
hier et la nuit dernière des rafales de
vent qui ont pu atteindre les 100 km
heure le réseau des rer a subi les
conséquences de ces intempéries sur la
ligne a le trafic a été interrompu une
grande partie de la journée entre
sartrouville et nanterre préfecture en
raison d'une panne électrique est aussi
à a servi la cause de la présence d'un
arbre sur les voies d impact également
sur le rer b et le rer c avec une
circulation fortement ralenti ce matin
suite à un défaut d'alimentation
électrique
[Musique]
et depuis le 27 janvier un audioguide
revenant sur l'histoire des familles
juives de versailles pendant la shoah
est disponible sur votre smartphone est
derrière ce projet ce sont des jeunes
qui l'ont réalisé la classe de 3e 2 du
collège charles péguy du chesnay
rocancourt d'ailleurs trois de ses
élèves sont avec nous en plateau
cassandra julien et louis bonsoir à vous
trois est venu accompagné de votre
professeur isabelle coquillard bonsoir
professeur d'histoire géographie dans ce
collège vous avez mené le projet
également avec anne françoise pasquier
bonsoir tout à droite qui est donc
inspectrice en histoire géographie pour
l'académie de versailles et entre vous
deux charline avesnelles bonsoir bonsoir
rectrice de l'académie de versailles qui
vient nous parler d'un autre projet mais
on ne manquera pas de vous faire réagir
bien sûr sur ce dossier sur cet
audioguide de sur la shoah justement cet
audioguide
le principe de cette 2 e audio guide il
nous est présentée par marylène
iapichino votre visite commence devant
le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
à votre droite l'hôtel du département et
juste derrière celui ci la préfecture
c'est bien clara une collégienne en
classe de 3e qui vous raconte l'histoire
de famille juive versaillaise durant la
seconde guerre mondiale cet audioguide
numérique
elle a réalisé avec toute sa classe du
collège charles péguy aux généraux
concours téléphone dès qu'on arrive à la
zone de la première balise baïnes
géolocalise directement donc le parcours
démarre automatiquement
donc ensuite on clique sur itinéraire on
a toutes les balises on peut bien
choisis lors du coup dans lequel on veut
commencer 16 balises pour un parcours
dans la ville ou bien découvrir chez soi
depuis son ordinateur
donc on va avoir une map qui nous
présente toutes les parties
et après dessus donc par exemple je
clique sur la 7ème l'histoire avec où se
situe on va avoir un lien tout un texte
sur l'audio avec les images qui raconte
l'histoire
un vrai travail d'historien qu'ils ont
démarré avec leur professeur madame
coquillard au mois de septembre suite à
une proposition du rectorat de
versailles pour partager leur expérience
ils ont installé une exposition sans du
centre de documentation de leur
établissement donc là c'est au mémorial
de la shoah où on sait aussi rang en a
aussi rendu visite
tous les noms des juifs qui ont été
déportés a parlé pour aller dans des
camps d'extermination
il vous faudra environ deux heures pour
découvrir gratuitement l'ensemble de
leur travail
ce projet intitulé par les vivants a été
réalisée dans trois autres
établissements
le collège charles péguy et le seul
franciliens à s'être lancés dans
l'aventuré pour l'instant voilà pour le
fonctionnement le principe de cet
audioguide racontez-nous isabelle
coquillard est aussi anne françoise
pasquier comment a démarré le projet
comment vous êtes lancés dans cette
aventure à françoise pasquier pour
commencer alors c'était un projet qui a
été portée à l'échelle nationale par les
ministères et notamment par l'adn de la
direction pour le numérique éducatif et
le l'idée était vraiment d'associer les
compétences numériques pour lesquels
dans lesquelles les n'osant de nos
élèves sont très impliqués et puis
l'enseignement de l'histoire de la shoah
en entrant par les vivants c'est-à-dire
en entrant par l'histoire de ces
personnes telle qu'elle vivait en
l'occurrence ici à versailles et il
avait le coquillard comment es tu arrivé
cette classe de 3e 2 justement dans ce
projet d'un site à l'invitation de
madame pasquier tonique à l'inspectrice
d'académie que nous avons commencé à
travailler donc on a eu une année de
préparation de travail en archives de
nombreux échanges avec madame pasquet et
avec madame paillerie que je tiens à
citer qui est chargée de projet à la
direction du numérique pour l'éducation
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
qui nous a beaucoup aidés pour tout ce
qui est manipulation de easy travail les
montages sonores donc durant cette année
préparation et bien et tout un travail
de recherches en archives pour
sélectionner ces familles sachant que
nous notre collège et touché n'est donc
mon envie première était bien sûr de
travailler sur le chesnay mais eux
malheureusement faute d'archivés
conséquentes
j'ai dû me concentrer sur la ville tout
à fait alors je me tourne vers les
élèves cassandra louis jullien peut-être
déjà une première question quand on vous
a parlé pour la première fois de ce
projet louis qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé
j'en ai pensé que c'était pas mal
puisque qu'on allait découvrir des
familles qui ont subi
la raf et du cou donc ça vous à ça vous
a touché peut-être cassandra ses
histoires ses histoires de ces familles
juives des portages oui c'était assez
impressionnant d'en apprendre autant de
voir plus en détail ce puits se passer
pour les personnes en dehors des camps
parce que c'est quelque chose face un
sujet qu'on apporte pas à l'école on
parle surtout des camps de concentration
et pas ce qui se passe en dehors et
c'est une zone du cou qui est assez flou
pour beaucoup de gens ce que je trouve
assez dommage
est ce que vous avez appris des choses
julien quel bilan vous tirez justement
de cette expérience de cet audioguide
créé avec votre classe alors moi ce que
je retiens c'est que ça se passe ça se
passe pas forcément dans d'autres pays
mais ça peut se passer juste à côté de
deux ans on vit se passe localement on a
juste à faire quelques pas et ça y est
on y est et un revêtement
je pense que c'est très bien pour tout
le monde d'apprendre des choses comme ça
parce que ça nous apprend d'une autre
manière que l'acheva ça nous concerne
aussi
charline amnell votre regard sur ce
travail mené par par ces collégiens sur
aussi ce devoir de mémoire exercice
c'est un travail exceptionnel j'en suis
j'en suis très fier c'est un travail qui
est exceptionnel et qui est nécessaire
au moment où les derniers témoins ne
sont plus là où ne seront peut-être pas
là et donc ces jeunes et bien ils ont
été les acteurs historiens les acteurs
du fait de passer la mémoire et tout ça
avec leurs outils qui sont ceux du
numérique et sur le vécu et c'est ça qui
très touchant dans cette aventure sur le
vécu des juifs de versailles ceux qui
sont partis ou pas ceux qui ont été
déportés ceux qui sont restés voilà une
entrée très vivante et des élèves qui
sont les passeurs de mémoire avec les
outils d'aujourd'hui donc c'est une
aventure exceptionnelle
bravo à eux et isabelle caut qui reste
que ce travail est terminé ce que le
projet est encore enrichi non c'est un
travail qui fait des fédère l'ensemble
de l'établissement et comme le parcours
est ouvert à tous donc d'ailleurs on
invite les téléspectateurs à faire ce
parcours à déposer leurs avis puisque
nous allons amender notre parcours faire
peut-être des rectifications et est ce
que c'est un projet qui est voué à se
renouveler dans les années à venir
oui tout à fait le principe c'est
d'avoir créé des outils qui sont
réutilisables et notre souhait c'est
évidemment d'encourager les élèves les
établissements à s'emparer de l'outil
pour faire les recherches sur leur
propre commune dans leur propre
environnement
mais à julien cassandra lui je vous
donnais une dernière fois la parole sur
ce que vous retenez de cette expérience
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qui va rester
dans votre tête
nous y aller les familles qu'on l'a
rencontré pendant notre pendant notre
projet et et on a pu aussi découvrir les
les monuments
de la ville de versailles concernant le
projet et à son bras parce que fort
tonnage
moi ce que je retiens c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas pu mettre dans le
parcours parce que sur sade et les
tendres trop 20 de versailles c'est la
rafle de luz yen qui s'est passé en
juillet 1944
c'est un de nos témoins monsieur sandler
qui nous en a parlé
et comme lui je trouve ça important
qu'on s'en souvienne parce que on parle
on en parle pas tout simplement alors
que ça a été fait dans un orphelinat
donc ça touche vraiment et enfants donc
il ya ce petit côté innocent qui est
attaqué par les nazis et je trouve ça
important du coup d'en parler de s'en
souvenir comme monsieur sans gloire du
bien ça va ça va resté dans votre tête
votre tête durablement ah oui bien sûr
parce que c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
fait normalement
c'est un travail de mémoire qu'on fait à
partir des archives des documents
anciens et dont des archives privées de
la famille veille et qu'on a été les
premiers à découvrir et on sent
privilégiée c'est vrai les merci à vous
trois bravo à vous trois pour ce projet
mercier également à isabelle coquillard
et anne françoise pasquier le lien qui
s'affiche en bas d'écran pour plus
d'informations sur ce projet
charline abdel vous restez vous avec
nous en plateau pour parler dans un
instant d'un autre projet d'abord ce
dispositif pour redonner confiance aux
jeunes en échec scolaire ou à des
scolarisés
c'est l'objectif du dispositif
départemental remobilisation il a été
officiellement lancée vendredi dernier à
mantes-la-jolie chez les détails
d'horizon des lieux de vie serein pour
retrouver les cimes de soi c'est ce que
propose l'association entracte au jeune
adolescent yvelinois en décrochage
scolaire installé au sein de la maison
de l'enfance de mantes-la-jolie la
structure propose un accueil de jour
durant cette semaine tout au long de
l'année scolaire
on travaille sur le développement
personnel à les amener à se connaître
mieux pour pouvoir se réintégrer
on travaille beaucoup aussi exactement
sur sur les rythmes les rythmes de
sommeils première objectifs qu'on se
fixe et d'essayer de les ramener dans un
rythme qui va leur permettre derrière de
d'aller vers l'insertion
les jeunes sont adressés par les
services de protection de l'enfance
le département des yvelines a choisi de
financer entièrement ce dispositif
innovant
ça n'a aucun sens d'être comme nous
sommes un département particulièrement
performant dans les domaines économiques
dans les domaine écologique dans le
domaine urbain
dans tous les domaines à peu près de la
société et avoir des plaies sociales des
blessures social comme celle là le
programme gratuit pour les jeunes et
leurs familles inclut également du
théâtre et un séjour en corse
objectif générer de la confiance et
trouver sa place dans un groupe
charline à venelles qui est toujours en
plateau qui a changé de place rectrice
de l'académie de versailles l'académie
qui porte en ce moment un projet avec le
château est aussi si mme royal à cergy
unir ces cergy par université
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines est également la région
ile-de-france ce projet c'est créer un
campus des métiers de l'art et du
patrimoine au sein des écuries royales
du château de versailles l'établissement
accueillir est de 200 à 300 apprenant à
l'horizon 2023 déjà pourquoi porter ce
projet pour l'académie c'est un projet
qui
qui a énormément de sens on est dans les
sept mille mètres carrés des grandes
écuries de versailles donc c'est un lieu
qui est emblématique qui se voit du
monde entier et dans ce lieu est bien on
va y faire venir des jeunes qui sont
souvent très éloignés du monde de la
culture de versailles
donc ça va devenir le plus grand terrain
d'apprentissage sur les métiers du
patrimoine de l'art de la création d'art
de l'horticulture de la gastronomie sont
cinq grandes familles de métiers qui
seront présentes sur place ces métiers
ont besoin de fortes compétences quand
on voit lincendie qu'il ya eu à la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
tout le chantier qui s'opèrent depuis on
a besoin de deux métiers de fortes
compétences pour ces métiers oui
absolument
ce sont des métiers qui sont en tension
qui ont besoin de se renouveler dans la
formation continue qui vont être besoin
de mettre au plus près des entreprises
les talents donc du point de vue du
marché de l'emploi
vraiment on a besoin d'un endroit de
formation d'un an droite rance filière
trans niveau on formera des jeunes qui
iront du bac professionnel jusqu'à la
licence en lien avec des chercheurs et
donc l'économie et l'artisanat besoin
d'un lieu de ce type ils sont des
métiers qui ont aujourd'hui une renommée
mondiale
on peut le dire il nous avons un
savoir-faire à perpétuer dans lequel il
faut que nous ouvrions et puis par
ailleurs en effet qui est recherché du
monde entier et donc on pourra former
dans cet endroit dans cet écrin des
jeunes qui viendront d'autres pays
également
alors ce projet vient de recevoir le
label campus d'excellence qu'est ce que
ça change concrètement d'abord ce label
d'abord c'est une très belle
reconnaissance puisque ce projet a reçu
la note maximale
c'est aussi un moyen d'amorcer le
financement du projet puisque nous
sommes bénéficiaires
quelques millions d'euros pour amorcer
ce projet c'est un projet lourd
financièrement un projet à 50 millions
d'euros
et donc ça nous permet de commencer à
travailler et d'ouvrir un démonstrateur
à la rentrée prochaine
donc ça pour la première étape on aura
l'occasion de reparler tout à l'heure je
le disais dans le concret 200 à 300
apprenants qui seront formés autour de
cinq grandes familles de métiers on l'a
dit un site de formation que sont ces
écuries royal du château de versailles
mais l'idée c'est aussi de profiter des
autres sites de la ville pour mettre en
pratique les le savoir à qui je pense au
potager du roi aux jardins du château à
la petite écurie aussi ça c'est des
lieux qui serviront à mettre en pratique
les les savoirs acquis
tout à fait c'est le but c'est vraiment
l'ensemble du domaine du château de
versailles mais également l'école
d'architecturé mais également le potager
du roi vous l'avez signalé qu'ils
deviendront un terrain d'apprentissage
par exemple on viendra regarder les
corniches dans le château on viendra
ensuite travaillé avec des chercheurs
sur la pierre dans les grandes écuries
et puis on retournera dans son lycée à
montrouge pour faire la taille de la
pierre alors le calendrier vous évoquez
une ouverture partielle en tout cas dès
la rentrée prochaine ce sera pour une
expérimentation on peut le dire dans un
premier temps 600 m² ouverts au public
qui permettront donc de faire des
démonstrations d'orienter les jeunes de
délivrer des projets en lien avec les
artisans de faire du coworking de la
formation continue pour pour ces mêmes
artisans qui manque cruellement de lieux
et puis de lieux pour faire prospérer
également l'entrepreneuriat dans ces
métiers d'art et du patrimoine
donc ça c'est pour les 600 mètres carrés
les premiers 600 m² le reste du campus
en tout sera 7000 m² l'idée c'est de
proposer dès 2023 de ça mais c'est
d'ouvrir progressivement des espaces
cours en effet livrés complètement
l'ensemble du campus en 2023 mais d'ores
et déjà des actions commence nous
commençons à faire dès lundi de la voie
professionnelle ou des jeunes de la voie
professionnelle viennent tous les lundis
au château travailler avec les ateliers
avec les entreprises visite le château
par exemple et donc ça nécessite sa de
réadapter les écuries pour ces nouveaux
usages il ya 50 millions d'euros qui
vont être investis qui sont peut-être
déjà investi pour ce projet il ya il ya
en effet un gros travail de rénovation
de ce bâtiment
donc en effet on est sur une surface
d'environ 50 millions d'euros pour
laquelle pour lequel nous sollicitons et
bien l'accompagnement des collectivités
locales la région le département des
yvelines le département des
hauts-de-seine notamment mais également
des grands mécènes qui s'intéresse la
transmission des compétences et
particulièrement sur le domaine du
patrimoine vous parlais tout à l'heure
d'une ouverture dès la rentrée prochaine
c'est à dire qu'il y aura dès la rentrée
de des premiers apprenant sur place et
ce que des places sont encore ouvertes
ce qui est un recrutement qui s'opèrent
en ce moment alors en fait ce vieux sera
vraiment accroché à l'activité des
établissements donc on viendra passer
une semaine deux semaines trois semaines
dans son cursus dans une expérience à
360 degrés pourquoi 360° bien parce que
on pourra loger les apprenants donc
c'est quelque chose qui sera accrochée à
la formation dans les établissements
on ne postule pas pour ce campus on est
par exemple à sartrouville dans les
métiers de la mode des costumes et on
vient passer trois semaines d'une
expérience complètement inclusive sur le
site des ventricules et toutes les
informations sur le site de l'académie
de versailles pour ce projet qui se
monte actuellement à versailles merci à
charline hamel d'être venu en parler en
plateau et je rappelle que vous êtes la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
merci à vous
[Musique]
la page des élections municipales à
présent à versailles d'abord un duel à 8
se profile pour le scrutin
en plus des candidatures dont nous avons
déjà parlé celle du maire sortant
françois de mazières et puis celle
d'anne france ceux ci m'ont soutenu par
le député la république en marge des
yvelines didier baichère six autres
personnes sont en lice marc dias gamma
mènera le réveil démocratique et
solidaire une liste soutenue par le ps
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste
quatre thèmes de campagne axée sur
l'écologie solidaire révolution
démocratique révolution des usages
bien-être et bien vivre elle lui
souhaite parler surtout de développement
économique
arnaud mercier est à la tête d'une
énergie nouvelle pour versailles liste
de centre droit l'ancien conseil
municipal et créateur du club versailles
affaire donne la priorité au
développement des commerces et culturels
à versailles le rassemblement national
investi anne jacquemin chef d'entreprise
rassemblement pro versailles se base sur
les fondamentaux de son parti sécurité
politique familiale et lutte contre la
bétonisation dans les yvelines et la
région seule manque la ville a un maire
et rennes
l'upm l'union populaire républicaine
aura aussi son candidat dans la cité
royale jean michel boeri conduira la
liste versailles démocratie directe ils
veulent y lutter dit-il contre la
corruption et entend consulter
régulièrement les versaillais par
référendum est déjà candidat en 2014 le
conseiller municipal d'opposition fabien
bouglé est de nouveau en lice pour
versailles familles à venir
il définit sa liste comme de droite
républicaine et écologistes l'écologie
est d'ailleurs mise en avant dans son
programme enfin il est connu dans la
ville pour être investi dans plusieurs
associations engagées renault ans
violette également dans la campagne pour
les élections vive versailles écologie
citoyenne se veut écologistes et
indépendante
cinq valeurs bienveillance histoire
initiative positif et simplicité
voilà pour ces huit candidats pour ces
élections municipales à versailles
attrape à présent sixième réunion de
campagne pourra lire abeilles sa liste
pour que tu rappes respire vendredi
l'adjointe au maire de la ville a
présenté son projet en matière
d'éducation c'était à la maison des
familles
que la dendre i et nicolas kirillovitch
pour les détails c'est un engagement
pris par ali rabais et la liste pour que
tu rappes respire le retour à la semaine
des quatre jours pour la rentrée 2020
une annonce suite à un référendum auprès
des trappistes sur les rythmes scolaires
on organise un référendum pendant trois
semaines nous sommes allés au contact
des habitants dans les marchés en eau
chez l'habitant dans les gares dans les
écoles également et on a recueilli plus
de mille votants ce qui est vraiment
très impressionnant et qui montre que
les trappistes ont envie de donner leur
avis pas près de 80% les trappistes ont
décidé de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours pour ce sixième rendez vous de
campagne à lire à berre présenter son
projet éducation une méthode de travail
avec les directeurs d'école enseignants
et parents d'élèves des mesures
concrètes comme la réduction des tarifs
de la cantine ou la modification des
temps périscolaires rattrape plus
qu'ailleurs
nous avons besoin que les enfants quand
ils rentrent de l'école puisse avoir
fait leur travail en étant encadrés par
des professionnels parce que les parents
n'ont pas toujours le temps à la maison
où les compétences pour accompagner
leurs enfants pour préparer sereinement
la journée du lendemain pour donner le
goût de l'école aux enfants
au delà des apprentissages académiques
sur le temps périscolaire nous
travaillerons avec les enseignants
volontaires salariées par la ville
évidemment à développer des ateliers
ludiques et pédagogiques pour les
enfants
autre sujet d'actualité au coeur de
cette réunion publique l'avenir du
collège gustave courbet avec un projet
de démolition pour créer un collège
innovants et j'habite à côté du collège
roubaix entre autres quand je suis au
courant
cette future démolition du collège
j'trouve ça intolérable ali rabais sont
engagés dès le début de sa campagne
contre le tout projet de collège
innovants dont on ne sait pas trop ce
que ça veut dire
ce soir il a réaffirmé cette position
candidat de la gauche unie la liste pour
que très peu respirer soutenu par le
mouvement génération point s europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste français est la campagne
continue aussi à voisins le bretonneux
pour olivier à fond saut avec son équipe
ils organisent plusieurs réunions
publiques sur les problématiques de la
commune manon varaldo a suivi l'une
d'entre elles c'était au bar de la
providence
de quoi parle-t-on qu'est ce que vous me
racontez tout va bien à champ fleuri
olivier afonso tête de liste unie pour
voisins souhaitent une proximité avec
les habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux
le candidat s'est allié avec thierry
gastaud les deux conseillers municipaux
de l'opposition de la commune souhaite
faire face à alexandra rosetti maire
sortante avec thierry nous avons partagé
plusieurs moments lors de ce mandat et
l'union s'est fait naturellement
les gens le connaissent j'ai passé 10
ans à présider la sl qui est là
l'association syndicale libre qui est la
plus importante à voisins donc je suis
un élu de terrain et sur le terrain
justement ça coince côté circulation dus
aux nombreuses constructions des
problématiques abordées lors de la
réunion publique mais aussi le manque de
médecins
il faut soit prêt soit adapté des
infrastructures qui vont arriver
or le fais moi je crois qu'il faut un
pôle médical aussi au centre village
les seniors ont beaucoup de mal à à
à se déplacer parmi les propositions le
candidat souhaite mettre en place un
service de transport propres pour
assurer les déplacements des aînés à
l'intérieur deux voisins mais aussi
s'occuper des jeunes olivier afonso
souhaite la création d'une halle des
sports sur les terrains de tennis du
grand pré actuellement à l'abandon le
candidat souhaite redynamiser la ville
et créer plus de liens qu'il a
énormément projet surtout pour les
jeunes comme faire des événements à la
fin du mois
cette liste est très représentatif de la
population voisin qui cherchent à
obtenir plus de convivialité
olivier afonso va à la rencontre des
habitants tous les mercredis de 18h à
20h au bar de la providence à voisins le
bretonneux est l'occasion de la campagne
des municipales tv 78 en association
avec radio sensations propose des débats
entre les candidats des villes
saint-quentinoise yvelinoise premier
débat a retrouvé ce soir pour la commune
de magny les hameaux c'est à retrouver à
20h sur tv 78 ou sur la fréquence 98.4
pour radio sensations ou également en
replay tv 78 points comme aller on
termine avec les résultats sportifs du
week-end de michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir carhaix journalistes aux sports
de la rédaction tv 78 du football pour
commencer michael le championnat de 2e
division de district deux équipes et un
seul et même objectif survivre dans ce
championnat de d2 de district villes pro
recevait la réserve de versailles ce
dimanche 9 février après une première
période équilibrée ce sont finalement
les versaillais qui arrivent à faire la
différence
1 0 ce sera le score à la pause au
retour des vestiaires sous une pluie
battante et le vent les deux équipes ont
du mal à produire leurs meilleures
partitions versailles réalisera tout de
même le break score final 2 à 0 au
classement l'équipe 3 de versailles est
toujours 11e et revient à hauteur des
premiers à non-relégable de son côté
gilles proulx est toujours bon dernier
avec une seule victoire depuis le début
de la saison on écoute l'entraîneur des
villes prochain ils ont pris un petit
coup quand le faux pas relâché il ya
encore des matches à jouer
la saison est encore longue on n'est
jamais n'est jamais à l'abri d'un d'un
miracle pour continuer à croire au
miracle villes pro se déplacera sur le
terrain de montesson le dimanche 1er
mars également dû is portes ce week-end
déplace à priser ya un public qui répond
présent la troisième édition du touriste
porte a de nouveau fait le plein ce
week-end à versailles plus de 200
joueurs se sont affrontés durant tout un
après-midi amateurs comme professionnels
après deux saisons tourner autour de eur
stone le tournoi est ouvert à de
nouveaux jeux du football avec fifa 20
et league of legends le numéro un du
monde de lys porte qui vient de fêter à
ses 10 ans
l'idée c'était que
les jeux c'est un peu comme des
disciplines sportives on a beau être
sportif si on joue pas au rugby on va
pas forcément suivre le rugby donc à
l'idée c'était d'avoir plus de diversité
plus de personnes qui étaient intéressés
mais pas forcément sur un seul jeu donc
là ça a permis d'avoir des communautés
trois jeux qu'on peut imaginer qu'un
arrêt de quatre
les vainqueurs se sont partagé près de
4000 euros de dotation les équipes
pensent déjà à une quatrième édition
merci michael le reste de l'actualité
sportive notamment un résultat des
templiers d'elancourt en foot us à
retrouver dans un instant votre émission
le 7-8 sport sur tv 78 voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité et belle soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]
oh